the cyclists at canuck chase
need no encouragement to get out and
about
but the prime minister thinks that
others do he wants gps to prescribe the
exercise
to tackle obesity there was a mixed
response to the idea
in staffordshire i think it's a really
good idea because it'll help people get
active
being out in the fresh air the outdoors
it's good for your mental health as well
as your physical health
um i'm a nurse myself and we're looking
at doing some social prescribing
the only concerns i've got is the fact
that not many people have bikes
so if you're going to prescribe it and
these guys are trying to find a way to
at least
help people actually acquire bikes i was
going to pay for it in the long run
but did i'm in the taxpayer
no it's probably not a good idea right i
think i do have a bike it's
hit it's somewhere under a bunch of
stuff in my garage
but if there was like more cycling
infrastructure around where i lived i'd
probably be more willing and able to go
out on my bike
the prime minister says he's lost a
stone and a bit
following his battle with covid the
government said the virus had given
everyone a wake-up call
about the risks of being overweight
it's a big change in direction for the
prime minister
who until recently had been a vocal
opponent
of anything that looked like nannying by
the state
access to bikes will come through
doctors in pilot areas
where there's poor health and low
physical activity rates
it's a huge problem to tackle so
prescribing cycling is a good
start it's trying to increase
access for gps to be able to prescribe
and give more help to their patients
with
a bee so it's taking it more seriously
this time
pop-up bike lanes in manchester and
elsewhere
have been used to promote active travel
during covid
the government is promising to make
permanent changes to roads to make
cycling safer disadvantaged areas are
have greater levels of physical
inactivity
but also they tend to be the places with
least good cycling infrastructure
so this is where we're going to have to
work hardest
they'd rather be off-road here but the
benefits to their health
are just the same lisa dowd sky news
staffordshire